ما ستشاهدونه الان ليس جنونا فحسب بل هو
جريمه بكل المقاييس
اسم الرياضه بيس جمبين اي القفز من
القاعده وهي الاقصى من حيث الخطوره فالقاع
لا تقتصر على اي شيء معين اذ بامكانك
القفز من اي مكان عالم تقط هذا الشاب
فيديو لنفسه وهو يقفز من تلفريك بكولومبيا
يصل ارتفاعه الى 1500
قدم تقوم الشرطه باستخدام هذا الفيديو
الذي نشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لتعقب هذا الشاب ويقولون ان لديهم هويته
وقد اعتقلوا المراه التي ساعدته على
القفص اصبح يوتيوب وسيله مهمه في تعقب
الخارجين عن القانون فتل فريك وسيله
للتنقل من مكان الى اخر وليس مكانا للقفز
منه وممارسه الالعاب الرياضيه ولكن القلق
الاكبر يكمن في خطرها على الفرد فاذا لم
تعمل المظله كما يجب قد يموت المرء على
الفور وهذا ما حدث لهذه المراه عندما قررت
القفز مع زوجها لكن لا يمكن للشرطه ان
تمنع المغامرين من القفز حتى لو دفعوا
حياتهم ثمنا
[موسيقى]
لذلك